combien faudra-t-il de
soulèvement populaire pour que la
communauté politique la communauté
politique nationale locale comprennent
que nous n'avons rien régler des
problèmes depuis des décennies et des
décennies et ce qu'il faut qu'on en
vienne encore à brûler combien de
bagnols il faut que est-ce qu'il faut
qu'elle est blessée est-ce qu'il faut
qu'on envoie le gign pour comprendre
qu'on n'a pas réglé les mêmes problèmes
qui produisent les mêmes effets depuis
des années et des années moi quand je
discute avec nos adhérents qui
reviennent vers nous qu'est ce qu'ils
nous disent ils nous disent on en a
ras-le-bol de voir des gens qui se
renvoient la balle en permanence c'est
pas moi c'est l'autre 1 alors c'est pas
du ressort du national c'est pas du
ressort du local et voilà et ça fait des
années que la partie de ping pong dure
entre les différentes forces politiques
et que en bout de ligne aucun des
problèmes n'est réglé bâle a donc ça on
en a marre de ça on en a marre de ce jeu
da et encore une fois dans les
événements terribles qui secoue les
antilles à l'heure actuelle on est
encore dans ce jeu là ça ça peut plus
durer donc il faut maintenant que les
gens qui sont à la tête des institutions
comprennent que ils sont la solution
mais pour l'instant ils sont un peu le
problème voilà donc moi j'appelle
aujourd'hui
nos adhérents un continue à se mobiliser
pour nous apporter des solutions je
viendrai très vite pour vous apporter
des solutions parce qu'il y en a il ya
des solutions y a pas de fatalité
aujourd'hui très clairement en face des
monopoles des monopoles bouftou
aujourd'hui dans les territoires du
premier rôle c'est bien des politiques
publiques aujourd'hui envoient leur fric
systématiquement même vous avez des
grandes filières la banane la can que
nous passons notre temps à dénoncer qui
sait des centaines de millions d'euros
qui partent dans les poches de
quelques-uns sa part pas dans les poches
de tout le monde des infrastructures
aujourd'hui mais bon sang ça fait 30 ans
qu'on n'a pas trouvé le moyen de faire
un grand plan marshall une relance
keynésienne pour dire allez on va
s'occuper des hôpitaux on va s'occuper
des lycées on va s'occuper des routes on
va s'occuper des réseaux d'électricité
des réseaux d'internet mais bon sang
pourquoi est ce qu'on arrive à trouver
des solutions de ce type là donc c'est
ça la responsabilité et nos adhérents
nous disent on en a ras le bol d'avoir
en face de nous des politiques qui
passent leur temps à se renvoyer la
balle ben moi je suis assez d'accord
avec eux aujourd'hui franchement je suis
en colère parce que nous avons tous de
la famille nous avons tous des amis en
guadeloupe en martinique en guyane à la
réunion à mayotte est aussi dans le
pacifique on est tous liés on sent on
est tous des citoyens donc maintenant il
faut arrêter ce jeu ce jeu terrible qui
fait qu' il est la cause profonde que
rien avancer on va pousser encore
jusqu'à la prochaine crise je reviendrai
vers vous prochainement mais franchement
là au nom de mes adhérents je suis en
colère parce que nos adhérents sont en
colère a très vite